[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDY JONES: Hello.
Welcome to "Google Cloud OnAir."
It's a live webinar series
hosted by Google Cloud.
We're hosting these
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Sandy
Jones, and today, we're
going to talk about
Hangouts Meet Hardware.
You can ask questions at
any time using the platform.
And we have Googlers standing
by to answer those questions.
As well, I'll handle a few of
them at the end the session.
All right.
Let's get started.
So like I said, today, I want to
focus in on Google Meeting Room
Solutions.
I want to talk about Google's
Hangouts Meet Hardware.
Originally, we were going to
call this session, How G Suite
customers can use the new
Hangouts Meet hardware
kit to set up affordable,
reliable video conferencing
at scale.
But apparently, that
was a little too wordy.
So we went with just
Hangouts Meet Hardware.
But I thought it was
very descriptive.
So that's really what we're
going to talk about today.
You know, when it
comes to meetings,
generally, people hate them.
They, typically, to most people,
represent a productivity loss.
More than half of
the people we polled
found that meetings were a
wasteful use of their time.
And what that leads
to is most people
start multitasking,
looking at their phone,
maybe checking their email,
maybe not paying attention
to what's going on at all.
And really, most people
feel that they're
having too many meetings.
But the reality is, meetings
are actually increasing and not
decreasing.
Because at the end
of the day, they're
a fundamental part of business.
They're incredibly important
to bringing new ideas
to the table, creating
solutions to problems, and most
importantly, driving consensus
within your organization,
getting everybody
on the same page.
So we felt we needed
to find a solution
to make these time
periods that much more
impactful for the organization.
Now, not only are we
getting more meetings that
are getting less
productive, we're
being asked to attend
them from more places.
More employees are
working remotely.
But you still need to be
a part of those meetings,
no matter whether
you're on the other side
of the city, the other
side of the country,
or around the world.
And so Google looked into how
we could make meetings more
productive and more impactful.
So what we wanted
to do was first
increase the presence that you
could achieve in a meeting.
That would reduce
the multitasking
and really want to make it more
of a face-to-face experience.
I like to think of there being
a social contract in place
when you're face-to-face with
somebody that kind of demands
your attention and demands that
you be present in the moment.
As well, on top of all
that, the body language
that you receive while
you're able to see somebody
really increases your ability
to evaluate what they're saying,
what their mood is, and
really, what's behind the point
they're trying to get at.
We also spent a lot
of time analyzing
what makes teams successful.
Because, typically, meetings
are an important part
of any team engagement.
And part of what we found
in our rework with Google--
you can see there's a URL there,
if you want to find more about
these studies--
what we found was this concept
of psychological safety
was the number one factor
in making a team successful.
And that meant
that they had to be
not afraid to take risks, not
afraid to share their ideas.
And that came with that
face-to-face interaction.
That came with
knowing the people
you were working
with in a way that
was a lot more intimate than
over a telephone conference
bridge.
So Google took all
these insights,
and we rolled out our own
video conferencing solution.
We did this years ago.
And in the evolution
of Google, as we
went from a very small
startup to a multinational
organization, we quickly
found that videoconferencing
was an essential part
of our growth strategy.
Not everybody wanted to
move to Mountain View
and pay those real estate
prices and sit in the traffic.
So we found we had to have
employees around the world.
We also need to being agile
company that could adapt
to market forces very quickly.
So we employed video
conferencing solutions
to do that.
And we quickly found there were
some challenges to becoming
a video-centric organization.
First and foremost was scale--
we needed a tool that could
handle Google's scale.
Google's scale was
100,000 employees
in 50 different countries.
We also needed tools
that were easy to use
and would drive an engagement
level that we wanted.
So we built out our own
video conferencing solution.
It was made up of
20,000-- today, anyway--
20,000 videoconferencing-enabled
meeting rooms around the world
that host over 275,000
meetings every day.
What that adds up to is 10 years
of videoconferencing meetings--
or minutes, I should say--
every single day.
Think about that for a minute--
10 years of video conferencing
that Google produces internally
every single day.
And like I said,
through this journey
from being a
traditional organization
to a video-centric
organization, we
found there were a lot of
challenges and opportunities
both in the
videoconferencing space.
And so we needed to
build out a tool kit that
took advantage of those things
while it reduced the user
friction.
And so that's what these
four elements you see up
on the screen here-- really, the
hardware and software elements
of our meeting room solution.
At the core of everything
is Google Hangouts Meet.
It's a software
solution to provide
a high-quality videoconference
meeting from wherever you are.
The hardware is for
your meeting rooms--
so a hardware kit that
creates enterprise-grade video
conferencing from
any meeting space.
The Jamboard brings
the whiteboard
into to the video
conference world
and allows you to connect that
whiteboard into the meeting
so you can share your ideas
and creations with anyone
that's attached to the meeting.
And then the software
app allows you
to do that via any mobile device
so you can also participate
in that ideation session.
So it's these pieces that really
make up the Google meeting room
solution.
Lets focus in a little bit,
first, on Google Hangouts Meet.
This is really
where it all began
for Google videoconferencing.
We created our own tool,
delivered that over the web.
You just went to a
browser, typed in a URL,
and you were part of a meeting.
And of course, we've since made
that available on mobile apps.
But really, the idea is to
make it super easy for anyone
to schedule and join a meeting
without even really having
to think about it.
Because we don't want to set
any barriers to the adoption
of that video-first culture.
Now, of course, there's
not always a time
that you can get onto
a videoconference.
Maybe you're
driving, and you just
want to use the telephone in
its more traditional manner
so that you can still
drive along safely.
So we added a dial-in
to every single meeting.
Not only does this make
it possible to choose
how you want to join
the meeting and handle
that on-the-go
scenario, it means
that people, maybe, outside
of your organization that
are a little bit more
familiar with dialing-in
can easily join that meeting.
It also means you can reduce
the cost of a telephone bridge
that you need to support
within your organization.
Now, of course, there
are also those times
when you, unexpectedly,
need to dial out.
And that's another
piece we added.
So maybe there's a participant
you want to add in last minute
to your meeting--
simply dial their phone number.
And you can do that out
of any Meet to bring them
into the conversation.
One of the things I notice
when I walk around Google
is there isn't a
lot of desk phones.
And really, what's allowed us
to get rid of the desk phone is
this a capability for all of our
videoconference rooms to allow
dial-in/dial-out capabilities.
Now, the Meet
hardware, like I said,
that's intended to
make the meeting
space into an
enterprise-grade meeting room.
And really, it's a
fairly simple kit--
you see it there on the left--
but it transforms any space
into a video conference room.
And again, a nuance that
I've noticed at Google
is every single space here
is a videoconference room.
You can go and see a
two-person huddle room
that has a screen on the
wall, a camera, and a little
touchpad to join the meeting.
You can see large meeting
rooms of 20, 30 people that
are set up to host
large meetings that
have that same kit installed
with, maybe a different camera,
but it allows that large
room to be part of it.
So really the goal was to
create this hardware kit that
fits any room but creates an
enterprise-grade experience
that's easy to use.
Let's take a look at
it in more detail.
So at the heart of the hardware
kit is the touch screen.
That really allows you
to simply tap-to-go
to join the meeting,
control the cameras
and every other
aspect of the meeting.
Maybe you want to record
the meeting-- a simple tap
on that same touchpad-- and
now that's being recorded right
into your drive stream.
The speakermic was
designed by Google
to be a world-class
audio experience.
Basically, we want to reduce
the noise and the echo
that people were getting
over traditional speakermics,
so we've added that into the
mix and provided the latest
equipment and software
for making that
a crisp, echo-free experience.
The camera options--
there are actually two.
And like I said, there's a large
and a sort of small or regular
boardroom flavor.
For smaller rooms,
the Huddly camera
has onboard machine learning
that will crop and zoom
based on recognizing
faces in the meeting room.
So this will allow you
to maximize the image
and make for a great
user experience
without the users having
to do any zoom or pan.
It also has a nice
wide field of view
so it captures
people on the edges.
If you think of your traditional
four-person or six-person
rooms, sometimes they're
spread wide instead of long.
This wide field of view
captures the entire audience.
On the larger boardroom
size-- that's where you have,
traditionally, long
meeting rooms--
our Logitech PTZ 2 allows you a
10x optical zoom, if you need,
and the controls built
into that touchpad,
like I said, to control the
camera all from one place.
The brains of the meeting
room kit is the Chromebox.
We keep building these
faster and stronger and more
powerful to try and
optimize the quality
of the entire experience.
But more importantly,
these devices all
connect into that
Chromebox, and it handles
all the over-the-air updates.
So when we come out with a new
echo-cancellation algorithm
for that speakermic, it's passed
down through the Chromebox
to the speakermic
connected to it.
And you don't have to take
care of managing any of that.
It just happens
automatigically over the air.
Now, when you think
of Google, I hope
you think of the world's
easiest to use website--
one text box and one button.
And that's a design
philosophy that Google
tries to really bring to
anything that we build.
And I think we've done
an amazing job here
by keeping the idea of Google
meeting room solution simple.
It's first, simple
on your budget.
The goal in making
these kits was
to make a kit that
fit every space--
and I mean to put in every
space so that you don't
leave any space behind, right?
You don't want people having to
make decisions of whether they
have a videoconference or not.
Every room needs to be enabled,
so when they have a meeting,
the videoconference is
almost an afterthought
because it just happens.
But in order to
do that, we needed
a kit that was
affordable on your budget
and would fit into
that overall AV spend.
It needed to be easy
for your end users
to, A, set up a meeting, and
then, B, join that meeting
when they need to.
And that makes it,
in turn, easier
for you to support because
you don't have users
having to figure
things out or trying
to fix equipment in the room
that they should not be fixing.
So we made it very easy
for the end users--
built right into
Google Calendar,
if you use Google Calendar.
You don't have to do anything
other than invite people
to the meeting.
The meeting connection
URL is automatically
added to that invite.
When you invite a room,
that meeting information
is sent right to the
room where it appears
on the Memo touchpad to use.
So it's very easy
for your users, which
means less support you're going
to have to do as the AV team
supporting that.
And lastly but not least, the
ease of install, deployment,
and management-- so the
actual heavy lifting that
needs to go on behind-the-scenes
to make this experience-- we've
made that as easy as possible.
Fairly plug-and-play
on the installation.
You connect the pieces
together, a little bit of log-in
work just to get the hardware
initialized, and away you go.
From there, it's all managed
within the admin console.
Over-the-air
updates make it easy
for me to not have to
think about managing that.
And like I said,
the admin console
that you use to manage G
Suite-- it's the same place you
go to manage these rooms.
But not only that-- you
can manage its scale.
You can see where all your rooms
are at, what state they're at.
We've continued adding more
reporting and analytics
capabilities as well
as notifications
to let you know,
proactively, when something
is going wrong with the room.
We're also looking at ways
to help you improve your ROI.
And there's a twofold
strategy here.
One is that really
low price point
of these kits to
make sure that you're
getting an ROI on your AV
budget when you build out
every single space.
But also, we're providing
metrics on room utilization,
so you can take advantage
of that real estate
that you've paid for and make
sure it's being used properly
and not being left behind.
A lot of times when, for
example, videoconferencing
equipment goes bust, that
room just doesn't get
used for weeks and weeks.
But you're still paying for
that in terms of the real estate
costs and the overhead.
That ease-of-use, that one tap--
I think that's really one
of the biggest things I
noticed when I came to Google.
When I walked into
a meeting, all I
had to do to join that
meeting was tap on a touchpad.
And that's what we've
brought to market
with this latest version of
our Hangouts Meet hardware kit.
As I said before, when
you calendar your event,
that's really where the
magic starts to happen.
Google will help
me along the way
to figure out the right
room and the people
I need to invite and all that.
But it will also place that
meeting URL in the calendar
and send it to the room itself,
so I don't have to do anything.
I just go into the
room, tap, and go,
and my meeting starts on
the screen in front of me.
I mentioned the
over-the-air updates.
That means I don't have to
walk around from room to room
to support this hardware.
It simply happens when
we push out a new update
to any of the attached
qualified peripherals.
They'll receive that update
and implement that right away.
There's self-monitoring and
self-remediating capabilities,
so the system will try
and correct itself.
And you don't have to actually
go in and do a restart
or refresh the system
when something goes wrong.
It will try those basic health
fix options before it actually
notifies you.
And then, lastly, the automatic
peripheral firmware updates
that go right to that
Chromebox itself.
Now, all of this is actually
also leveraging something
that Google is very known
for in the YouTube space--
this global
infrastructure-- our ability
to pass video around the
world and make it available
no matter where you're located.
We leverage that
same infrastructure
of data centers and networks.
Google runs one of
the largest, if not
the largest software-defined
network in the world,
running our own pipes under
the Atlantic and Pacific Ocean.
My point being here, you're
getting the same ability
to move video around the world
that we bring to YouTube.
Now, one of the best
aspects of Google Hangouts
is the way it's
integrated into G-suite.
And that means a few
different things.
First, there's that easy
Calendar integration
I've mentioned a few times.
Once your room is
a resource, it's
going to show up in Calendar.
It's going to
automatically be suggested
when it's nearby
the user, and when
it fits the amount of people
that have been invited
to the meeting,
which is just going
to make that whole experience
of setting up the meeting very,
very easy.
The Jamboard is
also connected in.
So maybe I've paired my meeting
room hardware with my Jamboard.
It will ask to join the meeting.
Or I can just simply
type in the code,
and now make Jamboard is a
participant in that meeting.
Google Drive is
connected in here.
So when I do a recording,
it's going to automatically go
into Google Drive.
I get the same
ease of sharing it
with others that I do with
any file type in Google Drive.
And really, we've
made that super
easy from the
end-user perspective
of just tapping in and
recording on that touch panel.
And lastly, I've mentioned
a few times, the Admin
Console for ease of manage.
The other thing about
the G Suite integration,
though, is a Google
Hangouts Meet
is a part of that platform.
So right away, you're getting a
free videoconferencing solution
on everybody's laptop,
everybody's telephone
that they can begin
using right away.
So that's included in
that G Suite bundle--
that ability to videoconference,
to schedule meetings,
and really, have a
videoconference in my pocket
wherever I go.
I've mentioned a few times
this Calendar integration.
But I do think that's a really
key part of the experience,
so I want to really
highlight that.
You can see I've got a
little animation here.
As I'm adding
guests, the Calendar
is going to suggest guests--
not based on alphabetical order,
but based on a
machine-learning algorithm that
knows I work with Katie a lot.
So I'll put her at
the top because that's
who I'm typically meeting with.
Or these are some people I've
had some recent interactions
with, so let's pop
them into the list
as well because
there's obviously a lot
going on with them right now.
And as I type, it's going
to get even smarter.
So after I put in
an S, we'll just
have Scott and Srivatsan
on that list there as well.
And then, of course, when
it gets to finding a time--
once I've got my
guests-- maybe they're
not all available at that time.
I can look for times.
But the system will also
suggest times for me
and make it easy for me to find
a time where we can all meet.
Adding rooms-- it
will suggest rooms
based on the locations
of the participants.
So when I'm scheduling a
meeting for people in New York,
it's going to suggest
New York rooms.
But if I have a few people
out on the West Coast,
it'll give me two sets of
suggestions-- one for New York
and maybe one for Mountain View.
In the room, that
Calendar invite
just gets passed
right to the touchpad.
And so I'll see
all the events that
are scheduled for that day.
And I can simply
tap on my meeting
to join that whenever
that comes up.
And that touchpad has
full control capabilities
of both the camera, my
ability to record the meeting.
It'll also show me the
in-Calendar context
of the meeting.
So a lot of times, you
get going back to back
from meeting to meeting.
You're not even sure
what you're walking into.
You don't have time to pull it
up on your phone or your laptop
maybe, but you can just tap
a button on the touchpad
and see the details
of the meeting
and just get yourself
a few more seconds
of being caught up
before you jump in.
I mentioned the
Jamboard a few times.
And there's probably
a whole hour
we could put on the
Jamboard conversation.
But the idea here was
to bring the whiteboard
into the video conference world.
Probably a lot of you have
been on video conferences
where somebody at the other
end of the videoconference
has had a whiteboard.
You get this poor
experience and don't
get to actually
share in the ability
to create ideas or
correct problems
that are on that whiteboard.
Maybe you don't even get to
see the whiteboard very well,
because it's off to
an angle or not that
easy to see through the camera.
And if you think
about the whiteboard,
it's been around since people
were drawing in the sand.
It's that open space that you
create ideas and solve problems
or huddle around a
last-minute problem that
needs to be handled in a
new and unexpected way.
And so losing that tool in
a videoconference world,
we found that created a
lot of friction for Google.
We invented the Jamboard
to solve for that.
It allows you to connect
the boards to each other,
individually, or
connect into the meeting
and share that whiteboard space
with any participant that's
on there.
And as I mentioned, all of
this is seamlessly integrated
into G Suite.
When you deploy G Suite,
you get all the benefits
of Google Hangout Meet.
And when you add in
the meeting rooms,
they just become a
part of the Calendar
and a part of the
user experience.
Now, more recently, we've added
even more power to the Google
Hangouts Meet
capabilities, and that's
through a partnership with
our friends over at Pexip.
So we've created a
native interop solution
that allows anyone to
join a Google Hangout Meet
from a SIP H.323 endpoint, such
as Cisco, Polycom, Lifesize,
or from Skype for Business.
So really, what
this means is, when
you schedule an event,
the same way it easily
creates a link for
you to join a Hangout,
you now gain a link to join
from those other endpoints.
So I have the ability to
go onto a Cisco endpoint,
punch in my code, and
join in that Hangout Meet.
That's bringing that legacy
investment that you maybe
have in some of
your meeting rooms
and bringing that into the
Google Hangout Meet world
as well.
So if I have some spaces that
I've already heavily invested
in, I can now take
advantage of that investment
while still rolling out Google
Hangouts Meet hardware in some
of my smaller, less-used rooms.
It also means that,
if I'm working
with people that maybe aren't
on Google Hangouts Meet--
maybe they're on one of
these other systems--
I'm able to send them
an invite, and we're
able to collaborate
together online as well.
You can see here just
kind of a glamour
shot of all the companies
we work with on the Google
Hangouts Meet side.
I think the real
thick takeaway here
is that this is a solution that
fits customers of all sizes.
So whether it's a small company
that traditionally wouldn't
be able to afford
videoconferencing
or large organizations that
are really looking to increase
their collaboration and
transform their culture,
every organization can take
advantage of the Google
Hangouts Meet solution.
If you have any questions
on Google Hangouts Meet,
we've created this alias here--
meeting-room-pod@google.com.
So that's myself and my team.
We're standing by to
answer follow-up questions
or things that maybe just
go beyond the session today.
But definitely, if you'd
like to set up a follow-up
conversation, feel free
to reach out to this email
and get a hold of us.
So that's it for the
lecture portion of this.
Stay tuned for a live--
All right.
Welcome back.
Now I'd like to take a few
questions from the audience.
So we've put a few up here.
By all means, feel free
to keep asking questions.
We have people online waiting
to help you with those.
Let's start off
with the first one.
"What is the cost for the
meeting hardware kit?"
OK, so we have two flavors
of meeting hardware kit.
There's the regular size room--
and I think this is anything 10
people or less--
as well as our large
room kit, as well.
It's approximately $2000
for the regular size kit,
and that comes with a camera,
a speakermic, the Chromebox,
and the touchpad.
You bring your own monitor.
We didn't want to force people
into a particular monitor,
since different rooms
require different sizes.
And you may already have an
existing monitor investment
or screen investment that you're
able to take advantage of.
The larger kit, which comes
with the touchpad, Chromebox,
speakermic, and a Logitech PTZ 2
camera is approximately $2,500.
And you can find more
about that online as well.
"Why is the new
Hangouts Meet hardware
better or different than
old Chromebox for Meetings?"
So there's a bit to this.
There's the software side
and the hardware side.
So let's talk just the
hardware side for now.
When we first came out with
the Chromebox for Meetings,
the idea was to create a
disruptive videoconferencing
kit.
We wanted to find
a price point that
meant every meeting
space could have
videoconference inside of it.
And our first foray was to,
for all intents and purposes,
really build a kit from
consumer-available peripherals.
So the camera that
came with it, you
could probably buy at Best Buy.
The speakermic was a fairly
basic puck configuration.
It, of course,
had the Chromebox,
but it leveraged a remote
control instead of the touch
screen.
And that provided the disruption
that we were looking for.
It definitely allowed
companies to place these kits
in more spaces.
It was almost half the cost
of our existing hardware kit
today.
But what we also found was it
wasn't the enterprise grade
that our customers were
expecting from the G Suite
and Google products.
So we went back to
the drawing board.
We did do a lot on
the software side.
I'll talk about that
a little bit later.
But on the hardware side, we
re-engineered every aspect
of it.
So we introduced
the Memo touch pad
instead of using the controller.
That created a much
better user experience.
So instead of navigating up and
down and having to use a small
controller-- if you're like
me and sometimes forget
your glasses, that can be
almost an impossible task--
but it was replaced
by the simple touch,
tap-and-go functionality
of the touch screen.
We took the speakermic
and re-engineered
that from the ground up,
really focusing in on noise
and echo cancellation.
So you get a
higher-quality audio,
but you also get
less interference
and less distraction.
We also re-engineered
the Chromebox.
We continually improve that
and provide better specs
and hardware pieces.
And then lastly, we introduced
two new camera options--
one was the Logitech
PTZ 2, as well as
the Huddly camera, which has
onboard machine learning that
supports the auto crop-and-zoom
that I mentioned earlier
to make the maximum impact
for different users.
Let's see here.
"What's better about Meet
hardware versus joining calls
from my laptop?"
I think, really, it's about
what your use case is.
So the Meet hardware
was intended
to go in the meeting room space.
There's a lot of times when you
just need to meet as a group.
And by no means do I
think videoconference
has gotten to the point where it
outdoes the in-person meeting.
So you're still going have
people meeting in person.
But a lot of times, you're going
to have a mixed group where
maybe five of you are
in the same location,
but another five, or even
one person, is remote.
That remote person can
join from their laptop,
whereas the five of
you can be in the room.
If you've ever been
in one meeting room
where five people have tried
to join from the same laptop,
you notice it's
fraught with problems.
First of all, there is
the inevitable noise
that's created by the feedback
loop as everybody is joining
and their audio goes
into the speakermic.
You can reduce that by just
using one person's laptop.
But now everybody's
huddling around.
And really, you're only
seeing one person on that.
So the goal behind
the Meet hardware kit
was to videoconference
enable your room
and really make it so that I'm
meeting as if I'm face to face,
but I'm using the
videoconferencing solution
to do that.
The laptop is more for that
one person that's remote
or where I have to
join where I don't
have a meeting room available.
So really, I guess, to
answer that question,
it's really about the
space you're using.
And we would still
highly recommend
outfitting your meeting
rooms with the hardware kit.
We have a lot of investment
in our existing meeting rooms
with Cisco, Polycom, et cetera.
Is Hangouts Meet compatible?
And in short, I'd
say, yes, it is.
I just talked about
that Pexip partnership.
You can definitely find
out more by reaching out
to us or our friends at Pexip.
They're very excited about
this partnership as well.
What it really boils
down to is, when
you create that Calendar invite,
in addition to scheduling
the Hangouts Meet,
it will also provide
options for how to join
via the Cisco and Polycom,
and other SIP H.323 endpoints
as well as Skype for Business.
As I mentioned, this is
a partnership with Pexip.
So I would definitely
want to talk to you
about how you make that
available for your company
and what's involved in
setting up this integration.
"Hangouts Meet versus
Hangouts Classic--"
so this is really that
software question.
Before I talked
about the hardware
side of the differences
between the new Hangouts Meet
hardware versus the old
Chromebox for Meetings--
now let's talk about
the software side.
So the origin of Google
Hangouts was actually Google+.
So we built that as a
social media solution.
It was intended
that families could
meet using Google
Hangouts, or friends
could catch up even
though they were
separated by a lot of distance.
And while that was successful,
what was even more successful
was businesses using that
to conduct their business.
So that's what led us to bring
that into the G Suite family.
And like I said,
that was, again,
this intention of
taking a consumer tool
and disrupting the
enterprise space--
something that's very popular
with technology companies
these days.
And what we found was, although
we had a really good experience
with Hangouts Meet, there were
enterprise features that we
didn't think about in
that Google+ use case.
Recording is a great
example of that--
having that
high-quality experience
is a great example of that.
Phone dial-in and
dial-out are examples
of those enterprise-grade
features that really
didn't come up when you thought
about building a consumer tool,
but had to be a part
of the solution.
So Hangouts Meet really
represents an entire rebuild
of the architecture
of Google Hangouts.
And the focus, this
time, is on building
a tool that's ready
for the enterprise
and provides that
enterprise-grade experience.
"Where can I buy
Hangouts Meet hardware?"
So this is a geography question
as well as a tactical question.
So Google Hangouts
Meet hardware is
available in North
America, the EU,
as well as Japan and Australia.
We do have ways of importing
into other countries as well.
And it's really through
our partner network
that we do that.
So we actually sell the hardware
through our partner network.
You can go online on google.com.
Just search for
Google Hangouts Meet.
You'll find some places
you can buy online as
well through the Google Store.
But at the end the day, we
would recommend reaching out
to your G Suite partner.
And typically, they're
going to also sell
this hardware as well.
"If I have deployment
questions or need tips,
are there helpful
resources for me?"
Absolutely, there are.
One thing that we've
just soft launched
is a room design guide.
We are probably the largest
users of this Google Hangouts
Meet technology.
And we've used that experience
and put that into a guide.
Our own AV team has
actually taken their time
to build out a
guide that outlines
the best practices in terms
of designing the room--
from how you set up the
chairs and how you set up
your monitors-- to
the hardware you
need in there, and how you
connect it all together.
The email address
meeting-room-pod@google.com--
I'll repeat that again--
meeting-room-pod is a great way
to reach out to us and get
more information on that,
as well as there's a whole
host of materials online.
A best practices guide for
setting up your network--
that's something to
consider as you decide
you need to become a
videoconference-enabled company
is how do you make sure
your network can handle
that extra load?
We've got a lot
of best practices
on optimizing that network,
setting it up, and how to have
a great experience with that.
So with that, that's the
end of the questions.
I want to thank
everyone for watching.
And please tune in next
Tuesday for the next session
of "Google Cloud OnAir."
Thank you very much.
Have a great day, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]